climate change is coming and with it
rising sea levels that are threatening
coastal cities like San Francisco it's
hard to imagine what a few feet of extra
water sloshing around will mean but king
tides the highest tides of the year give
us a glimpse of the soon-to-be new
normal so the king tides are the highest
high tides of the year and as you can
see here when we have a very high tide
it actually over tops a lot of our
infrastructure in San Francisco in Marin
County all along the shoreline of the
San Francisco Bay these tides are a way
for us to visualize what the future of
sea-level rise will be like king tides
are caused by an alignment of the Sun
and the moon when the Sun and the moon
and the earth are all in alignment the
gravitational pull is higher on those
tides well right now what we have is is
the king tides that happen every year
they're a little higher than what we get
for normal I tides we have an El Nino
effect which involves warming of water
but makes the water higher elevation as
well and then a bit of a low-pressure
zone with the rain falling and that
allows expansion of the water even still
further as we see the water sloshing
over behind us that's that's what we're
going to see every single day 2030 2040
2050 depending on how climate change and
sea level rise go when you add the king
tide and the El Nino and the and the
storm surge effects together we can
start to see the kind of sea level rise
or the kind of sea levels that we're
going to see on a permanent basis by the
end of this century we might see five or
six feet of sea level rise so that's
that's water up at about this level when
the sea level does rise it's going to
swallow more than some sidewalk both San
Francisco's and Oakland's airports are
in the flood zone so are the
headquarters for Google Facebook and
hundreds of other tech companies and of
course California isn't the only place
threatened by rising sea levels
practically anywhere with a shoreline is
at risk engineers are working on ways to
protect home
businesses and infrastructure but with
around 40% of the u.s. population living
in coastal communities they have their
work cut out for them want to get a
glimpse of the future head to the shore
nearest to you on January 21st or 22nd